[Music]
foreign
watching The Press preview a first look
at what is on the front pages time then
to see what's making the headlines with
Rachel cunliff senior associate editor
at the new Statesman and Anna subri
Barrister and former government Minister
welcome to both of you as ever we will
turn our attention to the front pages
first of all
starting with the guardian there are
claims on the front of the Guardian that
more senior conservatives are turning
against the home secretary's racist
rhetoric uh quote unquote in the paper
at last a leader who knows what a woman
is reads the front of the Daily Mail as
they look at government policy on trans
rights
Junior doctors have been accused of
putting political politics above patient
safety that's the front page of the
Daily Telegraph it strikes are
pinpointed as a reason for patient
fatalities
families plead for disabled children to
get access to their own savings that's
the front of the eye as they look at
trust funds established under the former
labor Chancellor Gordon Brown
the financial times has a story
involving the financial consultancy firm
Ernst and Young which warns its UK arm
of fresh cutbacks and the Daily Star
says the cost of living crisis has got
people in a sweat over the increased
price of deodorants
front of the express looks at the Royal
Family its headline no appetite to make
peace with Harry the news of course that
he was attending the king's coronation
while the Metro pays tribute to British
fashion designer and miniskirt Pioneer
Day Mary quand who has died at the age
of 93.
while the front of the mirror looks at a
man who won Millions on the lottery
while serving time
don't forget by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can then check out the front pages
of tomorrow's newspapers while you
listen to our guests so let's head
straight to them to Rachel and Anna
um so let's start with the the very
latest on these investigation cell with
the FBI arresting a 21 year old Rachel
over this apparent leak of Defense
documents taken very seriously and
plenty of questions for the authorities
in the United States on this
yes one of the main questions being why
so these documents were leaked last year
a lot last week sorry
um and uh that they they are very
detailed classified documents referring
to the Ukraine war and essentially uh
American assessment of
Ukraine Russia various allies what China
should be doing what what South Korea
might be doing
um really classified sensitive documents
now they've traced it to this guy who
has been arrested uh who is 21 years old
and the the question really that a lot
of people are asking is what's the
motive here obviously it's it's too
early to to say but you've got reports
of quotes from from the first brand
saying that there might not have been a
political motivation he just wanted to
impress his friends these documents uh
were leaked on the social media site
Discord which is used a lot by Gamers
developers people into kind of Internet
culture and it's it's really kind of
worrying about someone who is
essentially a teenager would have had
access to these documents and might
despite the trading that he would
inevitably have gone through thought
yeah I'll post it on a social media site
just to impress my friends
yes and you know the motivation of what
happened here or what occurred here for
a nearly teenager a 21 year old will
certainly be examined and was it was he
a bad actor was he just boasting to his
friends the suggestion is that on this
chat uh room Discord he oversaw Thug
Shaker Central a group of about 20 or 30
people Anna sharing guns memes and games
and the suggestion from someone else on
that chat group was that first of all
handwritten notes appeared that appear
to be classified documents and then
photographs of folded papers were posted
um you know what was this a post just to
show you know I can join in this
conversation about Ukraine in a way that
you lot can't effectively but but
nonetheless the authorities in the
states we heard from the Department of
Justice and the Department of Defense
taking this extremely seriously
um suggesting that a criminal act has
been committed here
yeah I mean they've got to take this
very seriously because it is very
serious of course you could say that in
the past if you were wanting to
undermine your country's security and
the safety of its people it was usually
because you were giving those secrets to
another foreign power who was acting
against our countries or whatever
countries interests you were meant to be
defending and this is the peculiarity of
it it's not suggested that he's a
Russian spy or working for the Chinese
it just seems to be weird and he's in
with a group of rather weird people
who've got some unpleasant views on guns
and that sort of start rather you know
odd view of society and Americans and
Society in particular so look it is a
seriously because seriously important
stuff that should be secretive is now
being posted on on the internet in
effect
um but the motives for it are also
fascinating and it may be that yet again
it speaks more about the state of
American society
uh well certainly the guardian
suggesting that the top secret documents
were first uploaded from late last year
to March although Joe Biden uh when
asked by reporters in Ireland uh did say
uh there's nothing contemporaneous that
I'm aware of that is of great
consequence so he's trying to play it
down uh but of course they don't know
what is still out there that might be
revealed which is a of great concern no
doubt to the Pentagon and others
um let's move on to the eye shall we a
families plead for disabled children to
get access to their own savings uh
what's the context of this then Rachel
foreign
actually various campaign various
newspapers have been running campaigns
on it recently between 2002 and 2011
savings accounts were opened
automatically for children born in the
UK so if you were born between that time
the government opened a savings account
for you and indeed the government would
deposit some money 250 pounds for every
child uh or 500 pounds if for those who
are vulnerable or on low incomes the
idea being encouraging uh parents and
and everyone to sort of start saving
young for for these children they get
access to the money when they're 18.
however children or individuals with
learning disabilities who are are not
seen fit to be in control of their money
obviously can't access it so there's
this campaign underway as the first
cohort start to turn 18 with their
families and their parents trying to
access the money on their behalf it's
their own money it's the money belonging
to the children and yet the parents the
family families can't have access to it
because in those 18 years it seems
nobody foresaw that this might be a
problem so families are facing Hefty
legal fees to try and access that money
are often to buy crucial equipment or if
there are the children who are severely
ill to sort of uh use that money for
once in a lifetime memories anything
like that no they have to go through a
legacy legal process and you are seeing
increasingly more and more newspapers
take up the cause and point out that
this money belongs to these individuals
they just can't access it I mean this
Anna this sounds like the original
policy getting in the way of reality and
in fact why not have an even earlier to
pay for care I suppose
oh
yeah I mean the amount of money
according to AI for any individual is 2
280 pounds which isn't an enormous
amount of money but for that
child and for that family that is just a
big sum of money and they can do some
really good stuff with it and it it just
needs sourcing and there will be a
simple way of sorting it out if somebody
in government mind to do it so it's one
of those look just get on and sort it
and do it and do it now
and I'm going to stay with you for the
front page of the Guardian uh senior
Tori is turning against uh Sola
bravman's racist rhetoric this was a
former party chair was it not earlier
today
um you know what is the gripe against
her you know why is she not doing the
job she was set out to do small boats we
know as a main target for the government
etc etc so what what's the um you know
what's the background for this
so I shall try not to
um I should try to be as impartial as I
possibly can and give not give her any
benefit to the doubt we'll put it in
this way so you've got Sue Ella badman
who holds one of the great officers of
State who seems to be incapable of using
language that is decent and fair and
certainly befits the great office of
state that she holds and we've seen a
number of examples where she's used
language which is inflammatory and is
unacceptable but in recent the recent
last week this recent week we've seen
her describe Pakistani grooming gowns
um and giving the impression that the
only people in the United Kingdom who
have been grooming vulnerable children
are a Pakistan origin which is not true
and rightly people have criticized this
and are outraged the interest thing is
that finally the conservative party at a
senior level is beginning to call her
out now I think I might insane certainly
in the guardian nobody's actually had
the decency to be named and come out and
say what is absolutely the case is that
this woman is unfit for national office
because she uses well amongst other
things she uses language which is
inflammatory and is unacceptable and is
often she is factually inaccurate and to
see this on the guardian I think when
Parliament is back
uh when the local elections are over I
think we will see more and more people
quite rightly seeing her for what she is
and I think she will be at risk of being
in the next reshuffle removed she
certainly should be that's interesting
isn't it the guardian um Rachel's saying
that pressure is mounting on Rishi sunak
to intervene to protect the party's
reputation and yet here we are at a time
when labor is using personal attack ads
against both the Prime Minister and his
wife as their means of
um heading towards the election what
back end of 2024 we're learning
yeah
well I think there were sort of dirty
dirty tricks adverts personal attacks
sort of on both sides I remember when it
was Boris Johnson trying to associate
Kia stalma with the Jimmy Savile Scandal
uh and and all of that certainly uh
there's also been uh pmqs the Prime
Minister accusing starmer of supporting
people trafficking gangs or being on the
side of people trafficking gangs because
labor opposes a small boat policy so
yeah as you get closer to an election
both sides get more heated and you start
seeing these personal attacks What's
Happening Here I think is slightly
different I think Anna's right to flag
that it's important not just that people
are upset about the language that
swallow brother uses I mean we we know
that they are she was challenged in a
constituency meeting by a holocaust
Survivor about her use of the word
Invasion when it comes to talking about
migrants no the interesting thing is
it's senior Tories now who are worried
about this okay they're not being named
but you've got somebody in the guardian
quoted it as being a senior Minister and
Boris Johnson government who calls her
calls to algorithm and I've written this
down a real race is bigot and that's in
print in the guardian now conservatives
I think are getting really worried about
this particularly the worry is that
government actually isn't that
interested in Rishi sunax government or
in the conservative party as it
currently is she's interested in her own
future in pandering to the very right
wing of the conservative party perhaps
the possible leadership bid in future
perhaps uh a a place in the shadow
cabinet in a future regime or just
simply uh playing to the the right wing
think tanks and the speech circuit that
we know is very lucrative just look at
Liz trust so there are worries among
conservatives that her focus on on her
own personal ambition doing things like
getting upset that the police have
got involved with the pub landlord who
had the racist dolls rather
than making any sort of substantive
comment on the massive reform that the
police forces in this country very
clearly needs that she was quite quiet
about okay basically but she's becoming
a liability I think you're going to see
more and more of this as you get closer
to the election the worry that actually
she's doing the conservative party more
harm than good coming from conservative
voices
let's just take a quick look at the
Delhi Telegraph
um interesting here junior doctors the
telegraph says have been accused of
putting politics above patient safety as
figures Show Excess deaths almost
tripled after their strikes Anna figures
from the office of national statistics
show the number of deaths above average
increased significantly in the two weeks
during and after the first round of
industrial action by the British Medical
Association obviously second round is
ongoing at the moment but you know does
that put pressure on striking doctors
well I think the point is if I may say I
think that the doctors big fear is that
they're actually going to lose public
support I think they're probably just
about got it but not 36 which is
unrealistic and the danger is is that as
this drags on and people see the
profound effect it is having on real
people on patients I think public
support will drift away so the most
intelligent thing that AI both sides can
do is cut the rhetoric sit down and get
it sorted
yes and interestingly two of the two of
the biggest unions representing nurses
and other health workers are set to
announce the results of their balance I
think voting closes Friday uh certainly
I think the times were suggesting that
NHS nurses are expected to strike again
over their pay deals so great concern
obviously we'll see what happens when
that uh those ballots closed for the
Royal College of Nursing and for uh
Unison I think it is isn't it so plenty
to play for there anyway stay there with
a few lots more uh still to come on the
program taking a look at more of the
inside or the proper Pages rather this
on the front of the telegraph coronation
chin fired in a masculine blue
playing that one in a moment
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching our
press preview with me once again which
will come live senior associate editor
at the new Statesman and Anna subri
Barrister and former government Minister
welcome back to both of you
um Anna let's go to the Metro shall we
one of the papers that has decided to
lead on uh the death of day Mary quandt
um you know one of those absolutely
extraordinary names
um the swingy 60s and Beyond it's you
know there are very few people who are
effectively so famous in the world of
fashion and design
oh yes and I mean she really I just
can't um yeah don't even underestimate
the enormous influence that this woman
had not just on fashion but on the lives
of women so when The Swinging 60s was
happening I would be about what about 10
years of age so it really impacted on on
young women like me when I was a child
and you know she lifted the head as you
can see here which was revolutionary and
she championed it and she went further
than that because her fashion was
actually fashioned for all and that was
that was a huge breakthrough that you
know fashion was often for people who
could afford okature out of the great
French houses and what Quan did was that
she made clothes that well first of all
women young women wanted to wear she she
said be proud of who and what you are
fabulously youthful and then just
revolutionary and it but on top of that
she was a great businesswoman and she
did much more than fashion she went into
makeup with great success so all round
hero but really important I think in in
our modern culture especially for women
and dare I say it for the liberation of
women she she really was that important
in the way that women Broke Free from
some of the shackles that had held us
back for so long yes and even listening
to clips of her speaking in the 60s
talking about shoes saying I've never
worn a pair of comfortable shoes in my
life I want to make seamless shoes and
then the tights come from the shoes and
it's all one great seamless thing and
what your fabric is difficult because
women aren't 2D they're round I want to
make round clothes so think about this
sort of the the whole element of it
um but an icon certainly you know
adopting that video so soon bob haircut
I think I'm almost wearing it tonight
but not quite but anyway
um you know so you know she she lives on
and that and that's the point I suppose
isn't it Rachel
it is and just looking at some of those
photos that you had on screen a moment
ago absolutely iconic capturing an age
you could show those to anyone and they
would know exactly what what period you
were talking about
um and not not just mini skirts I'm a
huge fan of mini skirts uh but also
color types I'm a huge fan of those two
uh hot pants others have a raincoats
that she did uh onesies all of these
kind of things that Staples of fashion
today often we can sort of trace the
origins of them back to her design the
idea that women should wear fashion that
they looked good in but also felt good
in and could move in which is really
important as well I'm not sure shoes are
comfortable yet though are they maybe we
need to have a go at that one again
anyway let's get to our final story just
quickly Anna a coronation China not
China as I said earlier that makes more
sense doesn't it has been fired in a
blue color with the developer saying we
want to develop a range that was a bit
more masculine Anna
so so there we are I've just made this
sort of little speech about saying Mary
can't you know the great liberation of
women that took part in the 60s and for
young women like me and then what do we
see apparently oh my goodness me
coronation China fired in a masculine
blue what is a masculine blue and I mean
under Queen The Marvelous Queen
Elizabeth who we all love so much did we
have sort of what girly sort of Itsy
fairy sort of bits of I mean for
goodness sakes what a nonsense is that
it's blue
I just wait to be fair Blue China is a
thing right
thank you very much indeed